abone ol
Ama bu benim için İkincide diksin Ali
abi sağ olsun Yine her zamanki gibi
şeref verdi davet etti ev Ben Yapay Zeka
blok çayın Yani aklınıza Gelecek hafta
emaçi teknoloji ile ilgili bir şeyler
yapan bir insan olarak bunları kendimi
görevim olarak ve kendimi tanımadığım
şey olarak koymakla Birlikte Aslında bu
gün birlikte biraz amaçlarımız arayalım
istiyorum Neden amaçlarımıza alıyorum
istiyorum Ali ağabey ile konuştuğumuzda
la Ben 10 yılda 400'den fazla
konuşmacıyı saniye çıkartıp insanlara
ilham verdiğini video onlarca kişinin
Türkiye'de bu etkinlikleri etkinliği
dinleyerek söyleyen söylenenlerden Bugün
olduğu gibi anlatılanlardan Ufak da olsa
bir şeyler öğrenip hayatlarıyla ilgili
bir bakışı kazanmaya çalıştım gördüm
Bence bu çok kıymetli ve bugün biraz
iken buna bir saygı duruşu yapalım
istiyorum hem de bütün bu teknolojik
dönüşüm içerisinde gelecek nasıl
şekilleniyor diye sorgularken Aslında
bugün burada yaptığımız şey ne ona
birlikte konuşalım istiyorum
ya ben bu kaç sıfır birader başlığını
yazdığımda ve sosyal medyada
paylaştığımda bir arkadaşından bir
WhatsApp geldi dedi ki hemen sen
matematik hatası yapmışsın
değiştirebilirsiniz sıfır Toprak bile
olamazken söyle ekibe yazım hatası da
düzeltsinler falan dedi ki sen
çıkıyorsun rezil olma ben tabii ki işin
matematiksel boyutu daha sıfırlar
toplayarak bir varamayacağız gayet
farkında bile olarak Aslında çok uzun
süredir rakamların söylediklerine değil
anlattıklarını anlatmaya çalıştıklarını
oluşuyor Dolayısıyla Bugün de aslında
sayıların ya da yapılanların ya da
görevlerinin neler olduğunu değil o
görevlerle Neyi amaçladığını konuşalım
istiyorum Bugün hepimiz büyük bir Evren
izle buna çift yok Ali abi binlerce
Benden bahsetti akan milyarlarca
dolardan bahsetti sosyal medya
yanılgıların dan lezyonlardan
bahsedildiği sosyal medya dostlarından
bahsedildi Yüce bize bunlardan bahsetti
ve bütün bu bahsedilen içerisinde yine
onlarca yeni bilgiyle Tanıştık bir sürü
bilgi bombardımanı Cup
ama benim için bu büyük ve evreni
Aslında sıfır kavramını siz isterseniz
vaka ustayım isterseniz bilinmezlik din
İsterseniz biz sorgulamamız gereken yada
bir andan çıkartmamız gereken veriler
bütün değil bizim için aslında ortada bu
kadar ve içerisine hiçbir şey yok ve
bugün bu sahnede ve daha önce bu sahnede
yer alan onlarca insan yüzlerce insan
aslında bütün bu sıfırlar içerisinde
müziği bile götürmeye çalışıyor bize bir
amacı doğrultusunda nereye varmaya
çalıştıklarını ne yapmak istediklerini
anlatmaya çalışıyor ben Dolayısıyla
büyükleri kavramına bu sıfırla bile
arasındaki geçiş diye bakıyorum
hayatımızda bir sürü sıfır var Her gün
bir şeyler deniyoruz Tamam mekanda
batırmış
Sen git Yücel Bir işletmede üst düzey
öncelik yapıyor hatalar yapıyor
görevlerini iyi yazıyor kötü yerine
getiriyor ya da Umut pandemi döneminde
Evde otururken bir şey yapamadığı için
kendini işlevsiz hissediyor ve bir amaç
doğrultusunda kendini sokağa atmak
istiyor bütün bu hikaye serisinde
aslında bütün bu veriler bize bir
amacımız olması gerektiğini ortaya
koyuyor Çünkü görevlerimiz her zaman çok
iyi yapamıyoruz her zaman yapamıyoruz da
bazen görevimiz olsun diye para kazanmak
için yere başka sahipler L bir şeylerin
peşinde koşuyoruz ama gün sonunda çoğu
zaman elimizde sıfır kalıyor ve bugün
bizi hatalı kusurlu birer makine yapan
aslında diğer makinelere göre
kusurlarıyla yaşamamızı sağlayan şey
yaptığımız görevlerdeki mükemmeliyet
değil amaçlarının peşinde koşan insanlar
olmamız Dolayısıyla bu büyük Veli
kavramı içerisinde bütün bu karmaşa
içerisinde Bedirlerle amaçlarımız
arasında ilişki kuran
O çok az fabrika hatası diyebileceğimiz
kitleniz bugün bu sahnede yer alan ve
tekrar söylüyorum daha önce sahnede yer
almış olan onlarca insan birer fabrika
hatası
ama hepsi bir de bu büyük Veli kavramı
içerisinde büyük veriler içerisinde
yaşanmışlıklar içerisinde onlarca
başımıza gelen hikaye arasında doğru
amaçla bulmaya çalışan insanlar bizim
için ilişki kuran insanlar Biz bugün
yine çok farklı kişilerden hayatlarıyla
ilgili yaptıkları görevlerle ilgili
nasıl ilişkiler kurduklarını öğrendik ve
dolayısıyla büyük veriyle kararımız
arasında onlarca veri arasından nasıl
karar ülkemiz noktasında öğreticilerle
bir araya geldik bütün bu üreticiler
bizim aynı zamanda zihin haritamızı
ortaya koydu Bugün biz Caner'den bir
öğrencinin nasıl direnç gösterirken
nasıl umut dolu bir hikaye
yaratabileceğini nasıl öğrenim
gerçekleştirebileceği ne nasıl
oyunlaştırma kavramıyla bambaşka bir
eğitim sitesi geliştirilebileceğini
anlattı burada Jenner aslında Sadece
görevi olduğu için değil amacı olduğu
için bu sahnede yer aldığı Dolayısıyla
zihnimizde inşa ettiğimiz eğitim keşif
mukayese deneyim aklına
bu gelebilecek bütün bilgileri bugün
öğrendiğimiz her şeyi zihnimizde falan
her şeyi bir imza olarak zihnimizi atan
Buradaki insanların tamamı bu insanlar
sayesinde biz sadece görevleri değil
amaçları da olan insanlar olduğumuzu
öğrendik bir ceza Dolayısıyla bu
zihnimizde oluşan bütün bu verilerin
verilerden daha öte bir şeyin bir amacın
doğrultusunda hareket etmemiz
gerektiğini de
bu peki bu İnsan zihni Aslında baktığın
zaman bütün bu eğitimlerin öğrenimlerini
dışında geldiğimiz dünyada geleceği
yeniden şekillendirdiğimiz bu evrende
internette yapay zeka ile ilgili bir şey
aradığında niye hala işimizi elimizden
alacak mı Dünyayı ele geçirecek mi diye
sorular soruyor niye bu kadar kaygı
kumkuması bir varlığız Aslında bu kadar
büyük çok havalı kaygılarımız var ama
bundan altı ay öncesine kadar Google'da
en çok aranan şey elleri nasıl yapmamız
gerektiği dolayısıyla daha çok
başındayız penis öğrenmenin de
başındayız milyarlarca genetik kodumuz
bize hijyen meselesine 2020 yılların
sonunda tekrar karşımıza çıkart
dolayısıyla çok büyük hayalleri olan çok
büyük amaçları olan şirketler bireyler
olarak daha çok başında olduğumuzu sırf
Google aradıklarımız dan biri
çıkartabiliriz ya selamlaşma penis
teknoloji konuşmaya da geleceği
şekillendirmeye bak konusuna girip
girmeden önce selamlaşma mızın Nasıl
yeniden şekillendirir tartışalım mı
bu Fatih kültürlere farklı coğrafyalara
farklı insanlara göre yumruk yapan
dirsek vuran ayakta pika tane insanlar
hale geldik ve bunları hiç
hatırlamıyoruz bundan Birkaç yıl önce ne
Birkaç yıl önce birkaç önce herhangi bir
üst düzey yönetici yumrukla selamlaşma
yaptığında Kim bu bildiği işte atmak
motivasyonunda yanıp tutuşurken bugün
bunu bir sosyal mesafenin ya da yeni
dünyanın selamlaşma biçimi olarak
algılıyoruz Dolayısıyla birşeyleri
yeniden şekillendiriyor Sak her şeye en
başından başlıyoruz daha büyük
hayallerin peşinde koşmadan önce 101
yaşıyoruz Dolayısıyla bütün bu süreç
sonunda bütün bu yeni öğrendiğimiz
hikayenin en başında makineler çağında
ve bugün yeni şekillenecek dünyada
makinelerle etkileşimi makinelerle
iletişimimiz geleceğimizi
şekillendirecek s henüz Onu da çok
başındayız Bugün 10 yaşındaki çocukların
uzaktan eğitimle Cep telefonlarıyla
konuşabilmesi cep telefonu ile çeşitli
iletişim dillerinde
3D resimleri büyüterek klik yaparak
kaydırarak bir şey bir uygulamanın
üstüne basılı tutarak uygulama silmeye
çalışması onların birinci seviye
makinelerle iletişim konusu ne kadar
başarılı olduğunu gösteriyor Bugün
dünyadaki 6500 değil 7.2 milyar nüfus
içerisinde herkes Erdi bilmezken bu
nüfusun neredeyse tamamı herhangi bir
makineyle gayet rahat konuşabilir
durumda Dolayısıyla geleceği herkes
şekillendiriyor ama şekillendirilmiş
gelecekte herkes birer aktör ve bu
aktörlerin adı bugün bağlantılı işleri
Connect kastımı dediğimiz bizi
bağlantılı klan bizi internette sürekli
dolaştıran sürekli bir şekilde post
etmemizi sağlayan Yüce'nin İlizyon
yarattığımız yaratıyor dediğimiz bütün
bu hikaye içerisinde hepimiz çok doğal
birer teknoloji kullanıcısız bunun
içinde eğitimini almak istedik
Dolayısıyla bütün bu süreç içerisinde
Bizi bu kadar yetenekli klan bu
teknoloji kullanmaktan ziyade açık
zihinli olmalı
o önlenmeye görmeye taklit etmeye açık
olmak ve açıklığı aynı zamanda kültürel
koz olarak da dört farklı başlıktada
sonra içselleştirmiş durumdayız Bugün
şeffaflığa işbirliğine paylaşıma ve
güçlendirmeye açık bireyler iz En
azından geleceği şekillendiren insanlar
bu kavramlarla barışık insanlar Bugün
dünyanın Görece kötü liderler tarafından
ya da Görece zor bir dönemden geçtiğini
kabul ediyorsak Bu dört tane temel
kültürel Koda sahip olmalarından yatıyor
ve bir o kadar da Umut kadar mutluysak
ta yeni neslin gelecek kuşakların bugün
on yaşında doğal bir teknoloji
tüketicisi olduk tüketici olan
kuşakların bu dili çok iyi konuşuyor
olması ve bu kültürel kodlara çok iyi
sahip olabilmesi nden yatıyor
işte Bütün bunların sonucunda Aslında
biz birer bütün bunları gerçekleştiren
içselleştiren paylaşan ve aynı zamanda
bir çeşitliliği barındıran milyonlarca
insanımız bizim teknolojiden ya da
teknolojik araç gereç ten dünyada bugün
200 milyar yakın teknolojik araç geniş
var üzerinde internet bağlı olan ceza
sayısı bu Biz onlardan göreceğiz sayı
olarak çok hız ama bugün Biz ikonlara
göre kıymetli kılan bugün otonom dünyada
teknoloji evlerinde bizi onlardan daha
değerli kılan şey bizim görevleri ne
kadar yapabildiğimiz den ziyade
çeşitliliğimiz Bugün farklı kültürlerden
farklı mutfaklardan farklı lezzetlerden
gelen nasıl sofralarımız varsa farklı
kültürel kodlar dan gelen insani yapılır
mız var ve kararlarımız ve
yaşadıklarımız ve zenginliğimiz asla bu
çeşitliliğimiz de dolayısıyla bizi bu
makinelerden günümüzün teknolojik
hikayelerinden daha güçlü kılan şey
teknolojik olmayan çeşitliliği
barındıran insani
bu Kırmız
Bu bir başka deyişle Aslında bize
makinelerle birebir kıyaslama
yapacağımız bu dünyada maalesef onlar
kadar iyi değiliz bizim bugün nefes
alıyoruz Yeter ki nefes alsın dediğimiz
ve nefes aldığı için Kıymet verdiğimiz
insanlar olduğu kadar bugün internete
bağlı bir nefes gibi internet tüketen
makineler var Biz bugün görebiliyoruz
diyebiliyoruz beş duyu organımız var ama
onlarında sensörleri var bugün verileri
kaydeder biliyoruz ya da bu elleri
yorumluyor biliyoruz ama onlarında blok
kendini var Club çözümleri var Yapay
zekalar var Dolayısıyla bu konuştuğumuz
herhangi bir 4 parametrede onlardan daha
iyi durumda değiliz ve Bugün iş
yerlerimizde bizim görev olarak
yaptığımız her şeyi yapabilmemizi
sağlayan şeyler bunlar
bu ve bu sebepledir ki dünyanın çeşitli
noktalarındaki Yapay Zeka blok için ya
da farklı sektörlerdeki teknoloji
girişimcileri buradaki endüstride
İnsanların bu kusurlarını insanların
daha zayıf olduğunu bildiği bu
yetkisizlik lerini daha Yetkin
olduklarını düşündükleri bu tarafı para
mı 4 parametre ile birlikte daha
kusursuz çözüm üretmeye odaklanmış
durumda dediğimiz gibi internetin yapay
zekanın blok çekenlerin sensörlerin
egemen olduğu bir topluma doğru
gidiyoruz geleceğimizi şekillendiren
teknolojiler Bunlar Peki biz bu geleceği
neresindeyiz sorusunu bana sorduğunuzda
ve sahnede bir final yapmak için burada
her aldığımda benim için sorunun cevabı
çok basit butun bu teknolojik araç
gereçler görevlerini çok iyi yerine
getirebilmek için var
ben de peki amaçlar yağmasa ne olacak
bugün görevleri Biz çok iyi yerine
getiremiyor Sak Bugün bir şekilde işte
işimizde Kavga ettiğimiz için işte kredi
başvuru olayını yapamıyorsak ya da Yemek
pişirirken birden canımız bir şey
sıkılıyor ve takılıyor ve tuzu fazla
kaçırırsak bu bizim Aslında dengeli
yemediğimiz hormonların problemi Biz
hepimiz bugün işlerimizi güçlerimizi
görevlerimizi yerine getirmeye
çalışırken Aslında amacımız olan bu dört
ormanı dopamin serotonin ok Sitesi ve
endorfini dengelemek için uğraşıyoruz ve
temel amacımız bunları mutlu etmek ve
hiçbir görev Siz bu dört amacınıza 4
olmamız umutlu edin diye yok
dolayısıyladır ki bu kadar Yapay Zeka
girişimcisi ve otomasyon peşindeki olan
şirket amaç olarak kendilerine bu
insanların kusurlarından arındırılmış
görev yapacağı makineler icat etmeye
çalışıyor Çünkü dünya dediğimiz makine
kusursuz bir şekilde işlemeye devam
etmek zorunda
var ya Demek ki söyle tekrar dönecek
olursak amaç bu metinlerin amacı ne Bu
modelin amacı ona verilen görevleri
yerine getirmek kendi amaçlarını bulmak
değil Dolayısıyla Bugün bir amaç başında
Konuşacaksak dünya yeniden
şekillendirecek s bu şekillendirmeye
yapacak insanlar görevlerini iyi ya da
kötü yapan insanlar değil bu dünyayı
şekillenmiş bir şekilde daha iyi
götürecek şekilde amaçları olan insanlar
bugün Sürdürülebilir tarımla ya da evde
aç kalmış Ben de bundan dolayı aç kalmış
insanları yemek götürmekle konuştuğumuz
bu hikayeleri dinlediğimiz insanlar
aslında bir amaca hizmet ediyorlar
görevli oldukları için yapmıyorlar Biz
teknolojik araç gereci buna kaşık da
dahil buna tencerede dahil Bunlar da
birer teknolojik alet hala görevlerimiz
iyi şekilde yerine getirmek için
kullanacağız ama en nihayetinde bizim
gün sonra Amacımız ne
ve bu amacı bulmadığım sürece bu
kullandığımız araç gereç Sadece bizim
görevlerimizi daha iyi ya da kötü
yapmamızı sağlayacak bugün insanlığa ve
şirketlere lazım olan temel şeyde bu
görevler değil amaçlar
bu ve bu amaçları bulduğumuz zaman
Aslında yıkadığımız şeyine Bugün bir
pandemi dünyasında hepimiz geleceğin
yeniden şekillendirildiği gelecekle
ilgili yeni söylemlerin olması gerektiği
konusunda hemfikiriz pandomin bir domino
taşı gibi bütün ülkeleri devirdiğinde
farkındayız dolu ya taksitler yerle bir
durumda ve biz o taşları yeniden dizmeye
çalışıyoruz Ali abi bugün bize taşları
yeniden bize yardımcı olun dedi Biz de
buradayız Dolayısıyla Bu yeniden
şekillendirme kavramında bu domino ların
sonundaki Kavram nedir bu dominolar da
var mı ya çalıştığımız şey nedir
bulmadan herhangi bir şey başarma
olasılığımız yok
ya o yüzden bana sorarsanız senin
yerinde ya da insanlığın yerine bir
hedef kendinize koyun Dersiniz ne
dedimse Dilerim ki Arkadaşlar hepinizin
görevlerimizden çok daha öldü
amaçlarınız olsun teşekkürler Erol